yeah well actually that's actually what
drew me to asking him because again the
longer you do this you you the more you
realize that how how integral those
people are to making it all happen you
know my integral part is standing over
there and he's been with me since
American Idol for 20 years I've never
done a tour without Jason
everybody everybody literally everything
he produces we write together like we're
like the best musical Duo ever I love us
um but we're because we are different I
think that's what's awesome we bring
something different to the table and to
have that stability with someone in your
career from that long ago and that you
still gel and you still create with is
so
it's rare it's everything it's rare and
it's also everything like I don't know a
lot of people that have that you know
and I'm I literally was just telling
somebody that I was like I'm the
luckiest person never like people like
my career is also because of that man
standing over there like they help you
create they bring out you they make you
comfortable because you know them well
enough like it's just the best
collaborative process I agree with you
yeah I I I'll agree with that but your
career is because of you essentially as
well I just mean no talents you know I
have a little bit to do that's what he
would say but like but no I just mean
like I but I do think that you know
starting out even like starting out how
I did like these other these you know
artists and contestants on these shows
it's like I love so many different
sounds so to kind of drive home like
what I'm going to focus on it it's why
I'm ADHD so he's been the person to kind
of be like let's focus I gotta ask you
because I I I I I I could never have
done what what you did you know in order
I love competition you see yeah me too
me too I just even with yourself
competing with yourself but I just think
it takes a a certain level of courage
and confidence to be able to go on on a
show yeah and break through that way I
mean I'm it's I'm not you know being
modest or anything I could never have
done that I I know what I'm capable of
which is hysterical though because your
voice is like what people are like I
wouldn't have done it I I wouldn't have
it it takes it I think a certain amount
of courage to put yourself out there and
be judged in amongst other people right
and be critiqued on a show on a world
stage I I don't know if anyone realizes
how hard that is you know to to actually
put yourself out there and people tell
you how good you were or how bad you
were and you haven't to take it you know
on a show like you did I I wouldn't have
had the courage to do that and and I so
I have so much admiration well thank you
I think the really good boot camp though
because it was really hard hard and it
was more hard not for me but to watch
other people I'm always that person like
it's hard for me to watch other people
go through something and like other
artists were not handling it well like
what people would say online and and it
was the first time the show was on or
whatever so it was that that was harder
watching people you know break their
Spirit a bit
um yeah I think and that that sucks but
I will say it was a great boot camp
because
after that I felt like I mean this
industry is hard you say you couldn't
handle it but you did because this
industry is not easy even if you're
selling eight million albums or doing
whatever there's always people just
trying to knock you down or say
something just super I can't say that on
TV but you went but you went from
nothing to all of a sudden but that's
the trick though that's why I think that
is the key when you have no home my
place had burned down I was living in my
car for a bit I had no like I had
nothing I had nothing and I think when
you have nothing you have nothing to
lose so you just show up and you go sure
you can laugh but if I'm getting paid
I'm laughing all the way to the bank
like I think you know at that point like
in my mind literally I didn't think that
it would go anywhere you don't I mean a
lot of people don't go anywhere on those
shows you know what I'm saying you don't
know and so I was literally just like I
need to pay my water bill I need to get
housing I need like you I think when you
when you're that desperate you don't all
of that stuff is like I don't even time
for that like these are real issues I
have I think when when that is your
that's why I think when everybody's like
they ask celebrities like oh do you want
your kid in the business which which I'm
going to ask like do you would you
really want your kid to thrive in this
kind of bit because it's a hard one
sometimes I I think my kid my kids will
never know what it's like to go without
to really have that desperation of like
having to push yourself and go for it
and and that's hard like to teach you
know I don't know if you can teach that
so then you don't want them to swallow
your kids up in an industry that's
that's hard I don't know what are your
thoughts
because I've often thought of that my
son uh Henry he sings and he has a great
voice yeah he doesn't think so but he
has a really great husky voice you know
but his dad is you that's hard
I'm just gonna say it but but then but
then you know if that's what he wanted
to do if he if he just it's my job to
just support him and as much as as much
as I I can I don't know it's it's a
tough one because obviously you know we
we've traveled that road and we know how
difficult it can be but ultimately my
advice to them is just to be happy but
with do whatever I don't care if it's
like if you've got to go and like sweep
the streets you know or or if you get
one life be happy yeah and and just be
happy because I I really believe that is
the point of it all is to try and figure
out how to be as happy as possible now
that sounds like a kind of almost
flippant thing to say and as no it's
simple but it's it's hard it's really
hard if you think about it because and
all that be happy and all that that
entails can I be happy if this person
isn't happy or if that person's
suffering or what Society tells you you
should be happy exactly exactly so if
they if they you know whatever they
choose to do whether it's music
um whether it's uh my eldest daughter
Laney who was actually going to be here
today but she has to go go back to New
York she uh she's modeling and I know
that's a kind of you know that's a
that's a uh yeah lots of rejection A
Hard Road to and you know she has a a
well-known mother never heard of her
but um but but as long as she's happy
and you know and I will say this for for
the kids of I can't call them kids
anymore because they're teenagers
they're young adults but they from my
sons and daughters I will say this they
got it a lot more figured out than than
I ever did at their age you know there's
you know I spend I spend way too much
time worrying about them and you know if
they'll find their way but the way that
they see the world is very different
from the way that we as adults see the
world you know they where we see
problems they see Solutions and and vice
versa oh I hope the younger generation
figures it out
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]